pour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france comment vous
accueillez cette annonce de gérald
darmanin va écouter mon salut cette
annonce mais dans le même temps j'ai
envie de vous dire que ça fait trois
quatre mois que nous demandons la
vaccination pour les policiers notamment
les policiers nationaux à l'instar
d'ailleurs de nos de nos collègues
pompiers savait que on réalise grosso
modo les mêmes missions en termes de
secours d'aidé d'assistance que deux
collègues pompiers et on comprenait pas
pourquoi nous ne pouvons pas bénéficié
de ne pouvions pas bénéficier de cette
vaccination
pourquoi c'est important d'avoir accès
en priorité à cette vaccination pourra
justement là les forces de l'ordre
écoutez c'est particulièrement important
c'est ce que j'ai expliqué à certains de
vos confrères
l'idée que nous on se posait des grandes
interrogations que nous avions c'était
de savoir précisément comment interpellé
en mettant en place cette fameuse
distanciation préconisée par la rs et le
ministère de la santé savez nous ne
sommes pas des magiciens nous les
policiers ont fait encore une fois avec
les moyens dont on dispose et
aujourd'hui une interpellation ne permet
pas de mettre en place la distanciation
tout simplement parce que nous sommes
parfois victimes d'invectivés nous
sommes victimes de postillons vous
pouvez vous m à 2 m ou 1,3 m ça sera
très compliqué d'éviter ces essais
crachats et quand vous interpellez
précisément que vous passez
éventuellement des menottes à un
individu tout simplement parce qu'il est
dangereux pour mu même dangereux pour
autrui ou tout simplement parce qu'il
est susceptible de prendre la fuite et
bien par définition on est en contact
direct avec la population et de notre
point de vue il paraissait évidemment
très important de protéger précisément
ce qu'ils sont censés protéger la
population
vous savez sûrement département les
alpes-maritimes nous avons aujourd'hui
un commissariat qui permettez moi
l'expression est sur le flanc c'est
celui de cagnes sur mer avec
successivement deux semaines des
brigades ce qu'on appelle des police
secours qui ont été infectés par le
virus et il a fallu avec les moyens du
bord et bien pallier ces défections
ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui clairement
on a encore une fois la démonstration
que la vaccination des policiers n'est
pas galvaudé elle n'est pas usurpée il
faut absolument la mettre en place
elle sera mise en place nous dit gerald
de dharma
à la fin du mois d'avril j'ai envie de
dire enfin
enfin depuis le mois de décembre unité
sgp police demande la vaccination pour
les policiers qui le souhaitent
déjà au moins trente agents de police
touché par le corvec 19
rien que dans votre département des
alpes maritimes a au moins quelle est la
situation exacte dans votre région
écoutez c'est compliqué en paca mais
vous savez les policiers n'échappe pas à
la règle c'est compliqué en paca pour
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
et bien c'est compliqué pour les pour
les policiers parce que le virus ne
décide pas de s'arrêter à la porte des
commissariats et pour tout vous dire
et bien il y a une véritable promiscuité
mais qui est de fait quand vous exercer
la profession de policier vous
patrouiller vous êtes en vase clos vous
êtes dans des véhicules de police vous
êtes dans des bureaux qui sont parfois
très exigu vous prenez des plaintes et
effectivement les biens les policiers
eux aussi malheureusement sont ainsi
pardon sont infectées par ce virus et
donc pour nous il était capital dé
mettre en place cette vaccination
elle arrive un peu tard mais j'ai envie
de vous dire elle arrive tant mieux
il mesure qu'ils arrivent tard c'est
long vo il ya quand même des mesures de
restrictions sanitaires importantes
prises dans votre région de confinement
le week end sur le littoral est-ce que
ça ça participe quand même à limiter les
risques pour votre profession oui alors
on s'est exprimé sur ce sur ce
confinement de week-end qui est plus un
déconfinement d'ailleurs j'attire votre
attention sur le fait qu emmanuel macron
ne parle plus de confinement ils parlent
de mesures pour freiner la propagation
du virus
vous savez ça a été très compliqué pour
les policiers ici sur les
alpes-maritimes
parce qu'un coup il fallait s'assurer
d'un véritable confinement puis il a
fallu ensuite peut changer un petit peu
notre fusil d'épaulé sur le 2ème
confinement qui était un confinement un
peu plus light
et puis aujourd'hui ce ce confinement
consiste plutôt à faire de telle sorte
que les nos concitoyens ne ne quittent
pas leur leur domicile à plus de 10 km
on connaissait la règle
donc si vous voulez c'est difficile pour
nous mais on fait appliquer ces mesures
on peut c'est difficile de juger
aujourd'hui sur ce sur cette nouvelle
mesure qui a été prise le week end
dernier je pense qu'il nous faudra un
petit peu de recul pour pouvoir en
parler de manière beaucoup plus claire
tous les cas pour le moment on sait le
ont fait le travail du mieux qu'on peut
mais malheureusement nous aussi nous ne
sommes pas à l'abri de vaciller c'est ce
qui se passe sur certains commissariats
aujourd'hui mais on tient bon je tiens
quand même à rassurer l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens marc alpin je crois que dans
une interview vous allez me confirmez
vous aviez vous avez dit les policiers
ne sont pas responsables du manque de
doses
pourquoi ces propos on a ce qu'on vous
reproche dans la rue peut-être d'en être
responsable d'être responsables de cette
situation la lenteur de sa campagne de
vaccination vous savez on fait un métier
très très compliqué alors je sais qu'ici
et là on entend les policiers passent
leur temps à se plaindre mais je vous
invite à venir un jour effectuées ne une
surveillance une patrouille dans un
véhicule portait dans un véhicule de
police
vous savez les policiers sont ceux sur
lesquels nos concitoyens tombe
permettez moi l'expression en premier
donc quand on a des griefs
quand on a des des choses à dire quand
on a des critiques a porté sur l'action
de tel ou tel gouvernement est bien les
premiers à qui on a affaire dans la rue
ce sont les policiers
j'ai pour habitude de dire que nous
sommes un peu de tout à la fois nous
sommes des policiers nous sommes des
psychologues
nous sommes des instituteurs nous sommes
des professeurs nous sommes des médecins
des pompiers ont fait une profession qui
est très difficile
on comprend le les difficultés vécues
aujourd'hui par l'ensemble de la
population les comprends parfaitement
ses difficultés vous savez avant d'être
policier nous sommes nous mêmes citoyens
et donc on les vit comme eux au
quotidien mais nous devons y être des
éponges et on se doit malheureusement de
prendre si vous voulez parce que c'est
la partie très difficile du métier et
bien prend un petit peu le tout cette
lourdeur que vive la population ce sont
les policiers qu'ils encaissent en
premier
voilà pourquoi c'est très compliqué
aujourd'hui et voilà peut-être pourquoi
un outil
il manque des doses mais nous ne sommes
pas responsables du manque de doses on
s'est appliqué les consignes qu'on nous
donne aujourd'hui notamment en matière
de prévention en matière de sécurité de
distanciation de port du masque et dans
l'espace public voilà aujourd'hui notre
notre job quotidien avec lui je voudrais
quand même vous rappeler que nous
développons cette thématique qu'ovide
mais vous savez que la police secours ne
s'arrête pas aux coville de tous les
jours les policiers gère des différends
conjugaux des différentes voisinage des
tentatives d'homicide
c'est à dire que c'est une mission
supplémentaire qui vient se rajouter sur
les épaules des policiers voilà pourquoi
aujourd'hui je ne vous le cache pas on
est sur les rotules
à force de tirer sur la corde ça devient
très compliqué pour la le service public
police et notamment pour les policiers
merci beaucoup à vous laurent martin de
frémont d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes secrétaire
départemental azuréen d'unité sgp police
des alpes maritimes